[Applause]
thank you I appreciate that it was uh
quite a week we had a big week for a
death and
and politics in one week Rosalyn Carter
Henry Kissinger and the first woman on
the Supreme Court shandre de o Conor all
all went to their reward in the sky and
we also lost George
Santos but he just went to abomi and
Fitch
but yeah Congress finally did it they
kicked him out
uh he'll be fine if it's one thing we
know about him he knows how to write a
resume no he was he was something
different that George Santos a gay man
and a compulsive liar I called him a
fabulous
fabulist
and he did not he did not go quietly did
not when they kick he oh he said
Congress you want to know about Congress
he said this place is full of felons
Galore by the way felon Galore is also
the name he uses when he does his drag
show felon's
Galore a great
name no he was mean he he's called the
uh head of the eth Ethics Committee a
dead and he also said Congress
I'll tell you about Congress there
there's people in here all all sorts of
shyy
backgrounds
shyy and marjerie T the green says shyy
I'm not sure what that is but it sounds
anti-semitic I'm
in
[Music]
um well let's uh let's see what's going
on in anti-semite news
there there's so much of it you know
with the kids today the the progressives
who who love Hamas um yeah they
protested this week uh rosn Carter's
funeral I don't know what that had to do
with it also the lighting of the tree
the Christmas tree at Rockefeller Center
the pro Palestinian people protested
that no Christmas trees that'll teach
the
Jews I uh
W but the big thing that I got excited
did you watch the debate last night
between okay I guess it got higher
ratings here because we had one of the
participants in it it was California
governor Gavin Nome against the Florida
governor Ronda santis and boy did they
take the gloves off Ronda santis kept
saying you know California must be bad
because people keep leaving it uh have
these people ever tried to park
here I don't think people are leaving
not enough um no he said California is a
failed State because of the leftist
ideology and Nim was having none of it
he said no no no no no no we're just a
big tent under the
overpass
[Applause]
um no I'm telling you Nome is good you
can't get him down I mean he turns
everything into a
brag about Cali at one point did you see
this d s just took out a map of San
Francisco showing where all the in
the street is I'm not kidding that
really happened at a debate and and nsum
was like well that just means California
has the most fertile Pavement in the
nation very
impressive but you know what at the end
of the day nobody's mind was changed
about anything right these things never
do what's going to make the difference
I'll tell you what's going to make the
difference Gavin usum is 6'3 with a
smile like a movie
star and DeSantis is 5'10 in
heels with the forced smile of a serial
killer okay
so so you you may not think that that's
what's going to make the difference but
I'll tell you this at the end of the
night desantis's wife left with
Gavin